[Music]
you never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one who kicks your ass some
fishies [ __ ] is happening on our Beach
and my balls say we need to go over
there and check it out is it bad idea
Mitch we're lifeguards my balls say it's
just take it he's right
well my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies hey watch works because we
follow rules
[Applause]
this is a train wreck I met Brody and
not a single [ __ ] was given is where the
best formers in the whole world it's
like if a human [ __ ] a jet ski which
is impossible but be so cool don't jack
off on my sheets just remember I'm
always watching
[Music]
Leona's
[Music]
All Things Considered things could've
got a lot worse foot that's good luck
pick it up
my dog we need search the morgue for
evidence
check his tank for needle marks the
woman to check his taint lifts his
[ __ ] scrotum and check his taint
dude it's a taint man it's Italian even
look get closer
Oh yogurt oh there's a hole that's just
his bottle all smile most of that do not
post that just a handful of ballsack
canals into the goddamn X Games that's
cuz we were in lifeguard pursuits oh
okay
except for this no [ __ ] such thing as
lifeguard pursuit
[Music]